[Musique]
vous êtes sur france 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir le burkina
faso à nouveau endeuillée par une
attaque de dia dit qu'ils auraient fait
au moins 50 morts parmi les civils c'est
l'un des plus lourd bilan depuis la
prise de pouvoir de la junte en jambes
en rdc les rebelles du m23 ont annoncé
avoir capturé la ville de bouna gare à
près de la frontière ougandaise
d'après les nations unies les violences
ces derniers jours ont forcé au moins
25000 personnes à fuir
et nous reviendrons sur ce plan d'
expulsion des demandeurs d'asile du
royaume uni vers le rwanda alors que les
expulsions vont commencer ce mardi les
oppositions se multiplient notamment au
sein de l'onu
on ouvre ce journal par ce massacre qui
a eu lieu au nord du burkina faso à
sepang à l'un des plus meurtriers depuis
un an les premiers bilans font état d'au
moins 50 morts d hommes armés seraient
rentrés dans des villages auraient tiré
sur des hommes écoutez la réaction du
porte-parole du gouvernement
lionel bilgo l'armée
ayant investi sur les désirs à koumassi
une recherche donc des victimes ou des
corps
jusqu'à ce matin l'armée avait retrouvé
à l'entrée dans le système à cinq ans
passant en revue l'ensemble des maisons
et au début de cet après midi c'est un
corps ont été retrouvés et les
recherches se poursuivent
cette attaque n'est pas encore
revendiqué mais tous pointent vers les
dialyses de l'état islamique au grand
sahara retour sur les faits que notre
spécialiste des mouvements jihadistes
oaci menace
d'après des sources locales c'est une
expédition punitive parce qu'on m'a dit
que dans cette localité en particulier
ça est un gars la population avait de
très bons rapports avec les autorités et
quand même il n'y avait pas de miliciens
parce qu'on sait qu'au burkina faso il
ya eu ce qu'on appelle les bdp donc pour
la défense des populations anti
djihadistes qui parfois quand il
s'installe dans une localité il attire
on va dire les foudres jihadistes là ce
n'était pas le cas il faut le noter
c'est une attaque de l'état islamique
donc ce qui a noté qu'il est sorti un
tout petit peu de sa zone de confort on
va dire habituel pour s'attaquer à cette
localité ce qui a poussé à l'exode quand
même delà de la population vers le
village de dori qu'on voit ici mais si
on revient ne serait-ce quelques jours 1
on voit toutes les localités qui ont été
attaquées avec les sur l'attaqué voilà
c'est une semaine ça on va pas revenir
plus loin parce qu'on la voit plus cette
place c'est malheureusement sur la carte
auquel vous allez voir il ya différentes
cibles qui ont été attaqués c'est pas
que l'armée et la police donc on voit
qu'il ya une multiplication des attaques
que les deux groupes se soit état
islamique où al-qaïda attaque de deux de
plus en plus poussant les populations à
l'exode et on skie aussi à noter là bas
c'est que ce sont des groupes on va dire
qu'ils sont qualifiés d'indiscipliné par
les groupes eux-mêmes on se rappelle du
massacre de soul and qui a été commis
par une unité qui appartient à al qaïda
khaled a dit que c'était pas nous
question posée on dit c'est une été
indisciplinés on soupçonne même les
unités de l'état islamique 62 ne pas
vraiment à répondre on va dire aux
ordres des maisons mères ce soit au mali
ou au niger donc ce qui rend tout ce qui
complexifie encore la situation parce
qu'on sait que les autorités au burkina
faso négocié avec les djihadistes essaye
de négocier de trouver des portes de
sortie on sait par exemple qu'ils ont
négocié à djibo pour sécuriser la ville
ouvrir les routes laisser les marchés
rouvrir sauf que ça n'a pas marché parce
qu'ils font des négociations au niveau
micro à un niveau très petit on va dire
de la chaîne de commandement et que ça
tient pas la route très très longtemps
et on sait par exemple aussi de sources
locales à djibo que les accords conclus
entre l'état et ces camps jihadistes ont
été mis à mal par les miliciens dvd p
donc ils sont hantés djihadistes donc
c'est une démonstration aussi de que
l'état n'arrive même plat même plus à
contrôler les miliciens qui sont
supposés être de son côté
l'armée française poursuit son retrait
du mali ce lundi elle a quitté la base
militaire de ménaka dans le nord-est et
pays c'est l'avant dernière étape du
départ de la force anti-terroriste
barkan du pays les nations unies eux
s'inquiètent pour la sécurité dans la
région qui s'est dangereusement
dégradées écoutez le ministre malien des
affaires étrangères qui s'exprime
d'ailleurs sur le mandat de la ministre
que le gouvernement du mali pour le
gouvernement du mali il est essentiel
que le mandat soit centré sur la
protection des populations civiles et
l'appui au rétablissement de l'autorité
de l'état sur l'ensemble du territoire
national
dans cette perspective il est
indispensable de mieux définir et
articuler la notion de protection des
civils dans un contexte de guerre
asymétrique comme cela interpelle
rappelé tout à l'heure par le distinguer
représentant de l'inde il ya lieu de
clarifier
contre qui on veut protéger la
population
sachant que la menace principale pour
vient des groupes armés terroristes on
passe en république démocratique du
congo où les rebelles 8,23 ont capturé
la ville stratégique de bunagana à la
frontière ougandaise les soldats
congolais aurait été forcé à se retirer
de la ville à peine 24 heures après
avoir affirmé avoir repoussé les
attaques des rebelles selon l'onu les
violences de ces derniers jours ont
forcé au moins 25000 personnes à fuir
les détails avec clément belin
selon la société civile les
affrontements ont éclaté tôt ce dimanche
le long de la frontière entre la rd
congo et l'ouganda l'armée congolaise a
dans un premier temps repoussé plusieurs
attaques des rebelles du m23 mais les
combats se sont intensifiés après la
tombée de la nuit obligeant l'armée à se
replier dans la ville de bunagana qui
est un centre très important de commerce
transfrontalier tôt ce lundi les
rebelles ont attaqué bunagana et l'armée
congolaise s'est retiré dans un
communiqué publié lundi soir l'armée
accuse les troupes rwandaises d'être
directement impliqués dans la prise de
boue ghana certaines organisations de la
société civile de leur côté affirment
que l'ouganda aurait également apporté
son soutien c'est bien la semaine en
tout cas les affrontements se sont
multipliés entre l'armée congolaise et
les rebelles du m23 une milice des fêtes
en 2013 mais qui a fait son retour en
novembre dernier la rdc accuse le rwanda
de soutenir le groupe comme il l'a fait
par le passé tandis que kigali accuse
l'armée congolaise de coopérer avec les
fdlr un groupe armé rwandais dont
certains membres sont issus des milices
qui ont perpétré le génocide de 1994
contre les tutsi cette montée des
tensions inquiète la communauté
internationale
l'union africaine a appelé lundi le
rwanda et la rdc a donné la priorité aux
pourparlers en cours à naïrobi ainsi
qu'aux efforts de médiation du président
angolais joint lorenzo de son côté le
porte parole du secrétaire général de
l'onu a appelé samedi un cessez le feu
immédiat et à condamner l'utilisation de
groupes armés agissant par procuration
la principale figure de l'opposition en
guinée était attendu ce lundi pour une
affaire de corruption cellou dalein
diallo et troupe sonnée d'avoir bradé
des avions de la compagnie nationale
alors qu'il était ministre des
transports du pays dans les années 90
sous la présidence de lansana conté mais
selon son parti le leader de l'ufdg n'a
jamais été convoqué les précisions de
notre correspondant malick tall
cellou dalein diallo a été convoquée
dans la matinée devant la cour de
répression des infractions économiques
et financières kiev l'opposant
actuellement à l'étranger ne s'est pas
présenté devant cette cour aucun de ses
avocats n'a souhaité s'exprimer cellou
dalein diallo est soupçonné d'avoir
bradé des avions de la compagnie
nationale aérienne air guinée pendant
qu'il était ministre des transports sous
le régime du général lansana conté le
dossier remontant à 2002 des accusations
que cellou dalein diallo a toujours
rejeté sa formation politique un lueur
des jets soutient que cellou dalein
diallo n'a jamais reçu une convocation
pour se présenter devant cette cour
messieurs c
diallo n'a pas reçu de convocation
s'il avait reçu il se serait prononcé là
dessus mais pour l'instant aucune
convocation ne lui a été admis en
parlant de droit
c'est une chose de vous écrire une
lettre c'est une chose
de voir une lettre est né dans la presse
ce ne sont que des supputations
il attend de savoir ce qui lui est
vraiment reprocher nos tentatives pour
joindre le procureur spécial de la cour
de répression des infractions
économiques et financières sont restées
vaines cette cour instauré par les
militaires au pouvoir a engagé une lutte
anticorruption visant des anciens cadres
des différents régimes qui se sont
succédés en guinée où passent à ce plan
d' expulsion des demandeurs d'asile du
royaume uni vers le rwanda qui suscite
la polémique
alors que les premiers vols devraient
décoller ce mardi de nombreuses
oppositions se font jour notamment au
sein des nations unies lagence des
réfugiés folle nations unies accusent le
gouvernement britannique de violer la
convention pour les réfugiés est mis en
danger un système international
d'entr'aide et de solidarité charlie
hebdo
les manifestants l'opposition et même
l'onu n'ont pas réussi à bloquer
l'expulsion de demandeurs d'asile vers
le rwanda 2 cour de justice ont rejeté
les derniers recours contre le premier
vol prévu pour mardi
l'accord entre londres et kigali prévoit
le transfert forcé de demandeurs d'asile
arrivés illégalement royaume uni il
vivrait dans des hôtels le temps que
leur dossier soit examiné en échange
londres doit payer près de 150 millions
de dollars puis d'autres sommes selon le
nombre de personnes expulsées la
sécurité des demandeurs d'asile qui ont
fui la guerre et la persécution est
assurée au rwanda mais les ong
s'inquiètent de les voir envoyer un jour
dans leur pays d'origine pour l'onu
londres ne respecte pas la convention
sur les réfugiés et son plan pourrait
encourager d'autres pays à refouler des
demandeurs d'asile
il existe deux des pays qui accueille
des millions de réfugiés je ne parle pas
du craignant je parle de pays d'afrique
qu'est ce que je vais leur répondre
quand ils vont me dire si un pays riche
comme le royaume-uni renvoi des réfugiés
moi aussi je vais le faire
le premier ministre britannique boris
johnson assure que le plan ne vise qu'à
sauver des vies de ceux qui traversent
la manche réponse de l'onu il existe
bien des moyens d'aider les réfugiés les
expulser n'est pas une solution
300 réfugiés centrafricains au cameroun
sont rentrés dans leur pays ils avaient
puis la guerre il ya plus de huit ans
entre afrique et vivait dans un site
aménagé dans l'est du cameroun nous
envoyés spéciaux mars l amoco et lucas
art mengo ont suivi leur auto reportage
vu du ciel le site aménagé dégâts d'eau
basés dans l'est du cameroun plus de 30
mille réfugiés centrafricains en
majorité des enfants ayant fui la guerre
vivent ici depuis 2014
après quatre ans passés sur ce site
c'est le grand jeu dur tôt pour cette
famille qui a fui la rca après les
violences entre groupes armés en 2018
elle va enfin regagné son pays dans des
pans entiers sont toujours contrôlés par
les rebelles mais le calme qui règne
depuis les mois dans la capitale bangui
les a convaincus de rentrée la compagnie
balma je suis contente de rentrer parce
que la vie devenait difficile pour nous
ici
la situation n'est pas complètement
stable mais nous avons appris que la
paix revient mes parents sont malades en
centrafrique et je me dois être auprès
d'eux
comme cette famille 300 réfugiés
bénéficient de ce programme de retour
volontaire conclu en 2019 entre le
gouvernement centrafricain le scr et
l'état du cameroun représenté à cette
cérémonie par le ministre de
l'administration territoriale
le départ est volontaire et sécurisé
nous avons déjà
convoyé trois départs volontaires on a
fait en 2018 2019 et 2020 nous avons dû
arrêter parce qu'il y avait de gros
navires us et c'était plus possible pour
nous de continuer plus de 5000 réfugiés
centrafricains ont déjà regagné
volontairement leur pays comme ses
compatriotes ce père de famille reçoit
quelques produits de première nécessité
de continuer quelques jours
sur le trajet du retour dans ces bus
réquisitionnés par l'ocr il y a à la
fois l' angoisse de l'avenir et l'espoir
d'un nouveau départ j'étais
[Musique]
métier de maçon navy losc et non mon
retour maintenant là quand je serai à
bangui la mettre en pratique
ma vie
après un voyage d'une demi heure arrivée
à la frontière entre le cameroun et la
rca symboliquement les réfugiés sont
remis aux autorités centrafricaines pour
ces rapatriés la nouvelle vie commence
dans ce site de transit avant de
retrouver leurs familles un retour au
compte-gouttes
350000 centrafricains sont toujours
réfugiés sur le sol camerounais
l'africa 6ème forum s'est ouvert ce
abidjan ce lundi vu comme le davos
africain c'est le plus grand
rassemblement annuel du secteur privé en
afrique meriem amellal est sur place et
elle nous décrypte les principaux enjeux
de cette édition c'est l'effervescence
ici à abidjan à l'occasion du africa si
au forum les participants sont tout
simplement heureux de se retrouver
physiquement après deux ans de réunions
virtuelles en raison de la crise
sanitaire une effervescence et un
enthousiasme toutefois balayé par un
contexte géopolitique inquiétant les
changements climatiques ont durement
frappé le continent la sécheresse est
sans précédent depuis des années et il
faut le rappeler aussi le continent est
largement dépendant des importations en
provenance de russie et d'ukraine ce qui
laisse planer la menace d'une crise
alimentaire grave une crise alimentaire
qui pourrait renforcer l'insécurité et
le terrorisme dans certains pays il
s'agit donc ici d'inviter les dirigeants
d'entreprises les investisseurs et les
leaders politiques à discuter à débattre
pour trouver des solutions d'urgence
mais à la fois à long terme tout en
tenant compte des enjeux
environnementaux
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
suivre le reste de l'actualité surprend
[Musique]